let's check check this out we got this
from the new york post gop primary
turnout suggests red wave in november
midterms republican primary voters
showed up in droves take part in
tuesday's contests
as of midday wednesday republican voters
made up 54.9 of the turnout in idaho
kentucky north carolina oregon and
pennsylvania according to data compiled
by jmc analytics and polling the figure
jumps to 60.9 percent of turnout when
all 10 states that have held primary so
far this year are included whoa
see that's crazy yeah yeah
wow quote in every state where i've been
measuring turnout changes relative to
previous midterms i'm seeing a clear
advantage on the republican side
oh man
well maybe maybe maybe maybe no matter
what they're gonna do that maybe some
people are waking up especially
independent even moderate democrats i
hope moderate democrats are saying what
they voted for is not what the they
expect to have okay look at look at elon
musk he tweeted just the other day that
for the first time he's voting
republican people are waking up and i
think that's a very i'm sorry but not
that voting republican is going to say
yeah that's what i was about to say
absolutely i mean vote republican over
democrat 100 percent but
you know a chain is only as strong as
its weakest link unfortunately in the
republican party the weakest link uh is
it's legal elected leadership yeah and
so what i would like to ask you lily is
what do you think the republicans should
do if they are able to take power
i think we should come out strongly to
tell people
you know why we are different from the
democrats party so we need to
differentiate ourselves
have you noticed in the past like 30 40
years like
everything just shifts to the more and
more left oh yeah yeah what then what is
the difference
so it's like a i just get attracted and
dragged and everything's going to let
now you we have to say where's the party
for small limited government and more
freedom for small working men and for
americans first you have to
differentiate yourself let's say when it
comes to right i mean there are lots of
you know women's issues around we need
to come up publicly support parental
rights and also
girls women sports right there are lots
of women who play women's sports and now
it's like they walk is basically it's
like where are the democrats who are
traditionally feminists now they're not
supporting the the girls sports and the
and seo is quiet about this i come out
the public support girls woman sports
biological men should not compete in
women girls sports and how about also in
our presence you have this work prison
system if you are prisoner you are
biological male you still identify as
female you go to women's room and you
got this woman president pregnant how do
we protect those women
so their lots of things are so confusing
and the left side is not consistent
at all when it comes to say oh we're
actually for a woman yeah one anyone
comes to abortion issue they support
women's rights to choose how about other
issues they don't talk about it yeah
when it comes to women's sports they
certainly don't have a right to choose
yeah just only when it comes to killing
babies we actually did a cartoon about
this this exact thing i want to
encourage you all to check it out but
it's leftist rediscovering biology for
this exact reason all of a sudden well
only women should be able to talk about
this now they have a definition of
womanhood and what a woman is lily i
wanted to follow up with you um i
believe earlier you said you were
against the 40 billion ukraine aid that
we'd be sending them um as the resident
neocon i wanted to ask you as we
continue as russia continues to be
isolated on the world stage they're more
desperate for countries to trade with
one of the countries that is capable and
seemingly willing to do so has been
china
what would you say to somebody who says
that we should support ukraine so the
chinese understand that whatever they
try to do with taiwan they're going to
face a similar result that is what's
going on in ukraine right now and that
by sending 40 billion dollars to ukraine
right now xi jinping is getting the
message that if he messes around in
taiwan you know taiwan might get 80
billion in arms funds so how would you
respond to somebody who says that to
stand strong against china we need to
send strong messages to russia because
again russia is needs china right now to
continue surviving how do you respond to
something like that they do have
alliance and they call each other
unlimited partners and here's what i say
first of all if i do get elected office
so what do i do i swear to protect the
defend it's not foreign countries it's
united states constitution
right
that's what the rand paul said he voted
he said also think about
all of those enemies want to see
destruction of america if we dumanize
our economy we become very weak because
we are creating money from same air and
inflation goes super high and then we
are putting all those printed money into
foreign countries so like a defend the
ukraine even though i'm first separated
towards ukraine people then united
states is gone so how can we be the
leader in the free world to defend the
freedom democracy
if our economy is destroyed absolutely
and if i could follow up there so um the
ccp constantly you know invades taiwan's
sovereign airspace and their sovereign
water threatening yes threatening yeah
so they intrude on these waters and the
united states has helped go through
those straits of taiwan and try to
establish some so i guess my question
here would be if china did invade taiwan
do you think that we should send
military aid to taiwan in that situation
well that uh certainly you will not
print all that money to do that big
right there's so much stuff you can do i
don't understand
our leaders how come are not really
pushed for peace talks why sure but
specifically if china did decide to
invade taiwan do you think the united
states should fund them as we already
work with taiwan in some capacity as do
we do many of south korea japan but
should we send arms the same way that we
are doing so now to ukraine to taiwan if
invaded by china because as i see it
without our assistance again ukraine
would have fell in in two weeks and
without our assistance to taiwan taiwan
would fall in two weeks well depends on
like right now i think the policy they
have they're kind of wishy-washy it used
to be only one china right only one
china
systems yeah well that did not work out
for hong kong people
and so so morally and strongly
economically we have ties with taiwan
taiwan has 80 percent of the world
microchip supplies so of course china's
eyes on those too but we should send a
very strong message to china now instead
of waiting for them to invent taiwan the
consequences will be unbearable for you
here is one two three four you gotta lay
out right now preventively i've been
calling on biden to do that i will help
him if he calls me and and also that
when it comes to alliances you got japan
taiwan all against china you got the
indian it's also and see china as red
you have all those aging countries we
need to form alliance with them right
now so prevent china from taking time we
have been supplying weapons to taiwan
already because we do not also trade
with taiwan but morally emotionally you
know we we will support taiwan but
essentially you don't want to push china
to even taiwan you should have sent them
a message now say we're gonna do this
this that so don't you know china of
course is rude by mama right now but
also be honest with you china's internal
economy is is weak and they they they
did a back down even in supporting of
putin because there's some messages to
send to china but but when it comes to
the um
taiwan it's kind of funny and the
chinese people are indoctrinated to say
oh taiwan is a part of china we need to
liberate taiwan at what cost and that
they don't know they're just
propagandalized and the taiwanese these
people actually they see what happened
to hong kong they don't want the one
country two systems and i think the good
strategy is also for them to stay status
call so you don't push either side you
you my strategy would be you don't push
taiwan to declare independence that
would just provoke china but you also
don't cut out to china let them to do
whatever they want so you need to have
some kind of balance foreign policy is
all about
diplomatic balances alliances and also
negotiate from strength not weakness
right now we're not
strong if right now we got word that
china had launched a ground invasion in
taiwan do you think the u.s should
intervene
wait boots on the ground or send
military aid to okay so should the u.s
help in any way
like so we've got strike groups we've we
you know we've we've sailed to the
strait of taiwan and stuff with our
carriers
i'm curious if you think if china were
to say you know like right now the
taiwan sent out an emergency call china
is is doing a hard invasion right now
should the u.s intervene
well it depends on when you mean
intervene i do not support we have war
with china i don't
we're not in a position to have any wars
and the congress should declare what if
they are going to declare war officially
per the constitution duties i have been
in this country for almost 34 years and
i have seen endless wars not declared by
congress but just by executive branch
there are some people it's like they
always want to you know constantly you
know meddling in the world affairs where
our country is getting weaker and weaker
so no boots on the ground but let's say
it was a similar situation where we want
to send 40 billion dollars worth of arms
to taiwan what do you think about that
well you you can look at the specific
numbers and they already send lots of
money to ukraine they ran out of very
quick and do we have a list of stuff
spent on and for this bill people don't
have time to read and to debate then
boom right now sent to ukraine and then
how do we keep track do you know how
much billions dollars the kobe still
means money wasted even bill maher is
very upset about that
you know you think he's a liberal but
he's like
what happens why are they still paying
money we cannot even keep track of how
many billions dollars got the fraud you
know skimmed
there that's how they handle your money
there are similarities a lot of
similarities between ukraine and taiwan
but i also think that there's really big
differences like the the already
diplomatic ties we have the taiwan all
the already military agreements the fact
that china's not just threatening taiwan
they've actually been sinking vietnamese
ships that they've been threatening war
with australia that they've been doing
essentially drive-bys of alaska and
hawaiian waters so while we do have
issues with russia
the issue with china is very very
similar
but also relatively different i would
probably fall into the
man i would not want to see a war with
china and and the conflict would be akin
to if russia and cuba like if if the u.s
if russia invaded guantanamo bay or like
not not not that they really would it's
not the same thing but the proximity i
mean so i'd probably say it's a really
bad idea if china invaded right now for
us to send in physical intervention at
that point it's like if it gets that
point we've lost taiwan yeah i think
there's a big there's there's a lot of
issues that are going on here but also
that it would happen quickly um right
they would they would surround it and
then they're in when despots get um
desperate to gin up support from their
population they go to war and many
chinese people chinese citizens are
primed to believe taiwan is a part of
their country so in order to drum
support in a desperate time xi jinping
may launch on you know a bad
strategically poor attack on taiwan and
trying to drum up support at home i
think putin's also trying to do
something similar with that but lily
what are you so is biden
that's why that's why you know i i don't
know what they did before even and putin
went to ukraine you know it's like a you
know you saw the signs on the wall how
come there's no negotiations and no you
know sections put into place i think
right now that we got to send a very
clear message to china what's going to
happen if you do take this step
and also the same time we need to
rethink about you know make our
country competitive again for all the
manufactured jobs that all sent to china
before and it's like
um people always blame corporations
corporations got to make money right
they go to go where the cheap neighbor
is and cheap goods are but as they're
saying is though the higher taxes in
america and also too much regulation
it's like you're pushing private
business people out to you know source
overseas so if you want to really have a
pro america you know like americans
first then you need to cut the
regulations you need to cut the taxes to
bring those jobs home
and and and why do we want to rely on
those countries anyway because we i
think as americans we had a delusion
about china oh if they just do free
market capital them get rich and they
will become democratic country it did
not happen
it got worse china is going backwards
now they are talking about this cultural
revolution 2.0 in china as i said white
guards red girls and xi jinping once
people now study his she's little red
books remember mouse needle read books
she has a xi jinping thought yeah a red
app for you to download on your phone
when you study past tests yes your
social credit score go up that's how
they keep track you it's a red app yeah
it's very sad and i think very telling
unfortunately about american psychology
and even american conservatism that
there was a very uh popular idea that as
long as we introduced the mechanisms
that would allow china to be to become
more economically prosperous they would
become a country that has values in line
with ours as well as a country that
behaves well and doesn't oppress its own
people
there was no reason for believing that
but unfortunately what's happened is
people have responded to marxism by
adopting its premises but trying to
argue from a different position so
rather than giving what the conservative
or traditional response should have been
which is well marxists are wrong because
there's more to the world than what is
purely material and simply having
material prosperity does not make a
country good or virtuous and doesn't
necessarily solve its problems what
conservatives ended up saying was and
what the neoliberal order ended up
saying was well actually it is the case
that being materially prosperous solves
all of your problems but capitalism does
that rather than communism i think we
tried to free trade our way into
relationships with china and russia and
like this upcoming era is us seeing that
failure at doing so so the idea was
liberalize china trade with china ping
pong diplomacy you know try to become
closer and then if we're tied together
then there's less risk of a conflict
germany had the same idea with russia
nordstrom won let's do another nordstrom
pipeline for the past decades people
were warning germany it's this is going
to be used as a political tool against
them but no germany argued that we need
to liberalize free uh free trade with
russia in um integrating our societies
and our businesses together we'll help
avoid conflict but we're seeing these
despots and authoritarian regimes just
use this um as a leverage against uh
other countries around the world
absolutely and it's because
we don't understand their thinking so
this is something lauren southern said
on the show but basically the chinese
government understands the way that
america thinks very well that's why they
come out in sport of blm and sa they say
the american police are racist even
though china is a horrific leader the
chinese communist party is a
horrifically racist regime you know
during a coffee shot down they kick out
lots of black people leaving china
mcdonald's banned them didn't it that's
it yeah and there's there's a sign to
say
you cannot go inside mcdonald's to eat
worse they have camps for uyghurs um
cultural genocide yes and and then the
racist ccp say they're saying that our
war corporations like this name and they
they have business with china and and
china is actually in a very racist
country and they were subject to their
rules but they're doing the totally
opposite here it's like
there's no consistency so it's all
follow the money right you know like the
same thing and
so i don't know say china has leverage
also against the free world because lots
of free world countries rely on china
for supply chains and they also look at
chinese 1.4 billion of them think about
how much money we can make from their
market and the chinese government knows
that they use their leverage to
negotiate to say hey
if you and support me in the united
states then when they should go to you
know like china market you know black
rock is manage china's pension funds
it's interesting that you mentioned that
they import most of their resources but
if somebody could fact check me on this
i believe they import 80 of their oil so
a quick blockade with um some of our you
know we have a ton of different our navy
is the true blue water navy on the
planet so it was uh
well no i hear what you're saying i'm
actually looking this up right now
yeah
another thing is that because the free
trade uh like american free trade has
facilitated the ccp in being the country
that it's trying to be so thanks to our
ability and allowing free trade to exist
on the world's waters they're able to
import and export they don't need to pay
to trust that you know the trading will
work out but in the future as we're
seeing you know this world order kind of
break down we'll be seeing less of that
so it's not reliable when you have a
political dictatorship right even though
i love free trade i love yes i we all
hope that free trade will bring people
together and don't fight the walls but
they're saying though when you trade
with a dictatorship country like russia
or china guess what you get one crazy
leader
that's not reliable of sudden you have
supply chain issues they can cut you out
and they can bully you and and and they
will use the money they made from you to
go expand their power have you heard
about china dream xi jinping has a china
dream by 2049
china will be number one dominant
economical and political military power
in the world how is it going to achieve
that
bring down united states
so that's why we need to be careful
there's the old saying it's attributed
to lenin though who knows if he said it
that the capitalists will sell us the
rope with which we will hang them
exactly yeah yeah we've given away our
manufacturing
yeah our borders have fallen
and now you have the talk of these uh
these these big international treaties
which on the surface don't sound all
that alarming then when you realize that
we don't make our own medicine
if china right now just cut us off from
manufacturing we'd be in serious trouble
like if we actually went to war we we
are we are we are in trouble i suppose
the the neoliberal idea was if we have
these trade agreements between nations
the war wouldn't happen but all that
happened was china started using it to
manipulate us
at risk this next era of the supply
chain is completely breaking down and
countries having to self-produce or just
with their allies it's going to have
huge consequences lily you mentioned
earlier it was like 80 percent of the
semiconductors in the world are produced
on taiwan
yes there's going to be huge
consequences to that other other things
like oil
a lot of this places is all focused in
one part of the earth so free trade kind
of helped facilitate that in trade but
as we see that break down um the
consequences will be dire i still think
leather
immigrants like me still say america
is still the
shining city on the hill for freedom
lovers all over the world so how are we
going to focus on our efforts and time
and to actually you know defend protect
our country
sometimes from enemies with yin
it's a big question
so and of course if we could you know
morally diplomatically economically help
other countries that's great but right
now
i'm just worried about america is gonna
fall
and then what gonna do who are we gonna
help are we gonna subject to the
the united nations
well they they give up our sovereignty
and uh but you know china is one of the
major players in united nations they're
on the council of human rights they're
on one of the things they're security
councils
on anything yeah and the who actually
did work with them and cover up the kobe
and the telling the truth to the world
and we don't even go after china to say
where is orange in of the kobe a where
is your patient zero
instead of we're just buying lots of ppe
from them yeah it just does not make
sense thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you